انا وزير الطاقه الاوكراني هيرمان جلوشيكو
ان المفاوضات بشان انشاء منطقه منزوعه
السلاح حول محطه الطاقه النوويه في مقاطعه
زاكوره جيا جنوبيه البلاد ما تزال متواصله
برعايه الوكالات الدوليه للطاقه الذريه
واضافا كالوشينكو خلال لقائه سفراء مجموعه
السبع وبعثه الاتحاد الاوروبي في كياز قال
ان طلباتي بلاده واضحه وبسيطه وهي نزع
السلاح من المحطه وسحب كافه المظاهر
العسكريه للقوات الروسيه هنا
جمل وكاله الطاقه الذريه على ترسيخ
الاستقرار حول محطه النوويه وتحاول انشاءه
منطقه رماديه حول المحطه طلباتنا واضحه
وبسيطه نزع السلاح من المحطه وانسحاب كافه
المظاهر العسكريه للقوات الروسيه من هناك
واعاده المحطه بشكل كامل الى السيطره
التامه للسلطات الاوكرانيه ووكاله الطاقه
الذريه
الى مطره اخرى بعد ساعه من استهدافه قبل
يومين واضاف اجنادت انه سجل خلال ساعات
الماضيه انخفاض الملحوظ في نشاط المقاتلات
الروسيه داخل الاجواء الاوكرانيه ورجعنا
عن ذلك الى الاضرار المحتمله التي قد يكون
قد تعرض لها المطار
بعد الانفجارات التي ضربت مطار انجلش في
منطقه سلطوف حيث تتمركز قاذفات استراتيجيه
والكثير من الافواج الجويه للجيش الروسي
تم نقل العديد من الطائرات الى مطارات
اخرى يمكنها استقبال تلك الطائرات
وصيانتها وخدمتها بشكل عام انخفض نشاط
طائرات العدو الى حد كبير خلال الساعات
الماضيه لكن يبقى التهديد حقيقيا انهم
يريدون الاستمرار في ضرب بنيه التحتيه
ويريدون كسر الشعبي الاوكراني